the investigators are revealing key
witnesses accounts of the night actress
Natalie Wood mysteriously drowned we
were the first to report yesterday that
48 hours learned Woods is then husband
Robert Wagner is considered a person of
interest
Wood disappeared in 1981 after boating
with Wagner actor Christopher Walken and
the boat's captain her death was
originally ruled an accident but
investigators reopened the case chest
over six years ago in this preview of
tomorrow's 48 hours investigators speak
for the first time to Erin Moriarty
about the key witnesses in this unsolved
case captain Dennis de Verne is
detective ray Fernandez and Lieutenant
John Karina's most important but also
problematic witness over the years he
has sold his story to the tabloids for
money and collaborated on a tell-all
book you find incredible I find his
story in his version of events when he
talked to us everything fit makes more
sense of what happened and it's
cooperated by other people de Verne who
spoke to 48 hours in 2011 says it was a
tension filled weekend fueled by alcohol
and Wagner's jealousy of woods co-star
actor Christopher Walken it just kept
getting more tense every minute of the
day turning ugly Saturday night I opened
a bottle of wine Natalie and Christopher
continued to giggle and then Robert
Wagner picked up the bottle of wine and
smashed it and he yells are walking
would you try to do my wife Natalie she
said I cannot take this and she went
into her room according to de Verne
Christopher Walken also went to his room
then RJ went into the room Natalie in
RJ's room started arguing yelling things
being thrown about at that point Davern
also leaves and goes up to the bridge at
the top of the boat says lieutenant
Karina he hears them arguing the
arguments getting louder he says it
sounds to him like there's like a fizzle
fight going on inside there he walks
back down and he knocks on the door he
Robert Wagner opens the door and he says
he has this look crazed look on his face
and he says everything ok boss and he's
like go away he looks so angry he says I
was worried about my own safety that I
just I left I went back up to the bridge
de verdun told investigators that his
line of sight was blocked by the boats
rain shield but he heard everything
fighting continued and then to the back
of the boat I was concerned that
something really bad was going down
because the fighting the arguing was so
intense
until now da Verne has been the lone
witness to that alleged fight between
Natalie Wood and Robert Wagner on the
back of the boat but investigators say
they now have two new witnesses who
claim they not only heard the fight one
of them says she saw it and how credible
are these new witnesses they're very
credible they have no reason to lie in
the and the their story matches what
Dennis tavern says but lieutenant Corina
says the stories don't match accounts
Robert Wagner has given over the years
Wagner won't speak to these
investigators but he has consistently
said that Natalie Wood's death was an
accident why does the case that is now
really more than 36 years old matter
because somebody died and no matter what
ultimately that's our job to find the
truth
Wagner declined our request for comment
but he reportedly told the New York
Daily News quote I've said everything
there is to say Erin Moriarty is with us
now good morning Erin good morning
Christopher Walken what does he said
well that's interesting Gail probably
knows and remembers that he has not been
very forthcoming over the years you once
asked him about it he does not want to
talk about it yeah no but what's
interesting is unlike Robert Wagner he
did talk to the investigators and they
have said he's not a person of interest
his story has changed a little bit like
what he said initially to the police and
then what he said in a Playboy magazine
so it's really difficult but they say
he's not a person of interest and how
likely do you think criminal charges
will be filed in and does a boat captain
have credibility at this point well they
say he does and his story really hasn't
changed that much over the years the
reason why we raised some questions as
he did originally sell his story to
Boyd's he collected money but they say
his story has stayed pretty much the
same over the years and it matches these
new witnesses Seminole charges well time
is not on the side of these
investigators remember this is a 36 year
old case Robert Wagner turns 88 next
week and the statute of limitation has
run on all crimes except for murder so
that's really with the focus of the
investigation at this point is is to see
how she got into the water all right
thanks very much Aaron you can see
Aaron's full report Natalie Wood death
in dark water on 48 hours tomorrow night
at 10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS